NARRATOR: Next, an
orchestra of students
from one of the world's
great science and engineering
universities comes together
for the world premiere
of a new piece of
music, a tribute
to the events of
the Arab Spring.
Meet the composer.
SHARIFI: It feels like
actually the tempo of it
slides a little bit.
HARRIS: Yes.
NARRATOR: The conductor.
HARRIS: If you end a
phrase with a quarter note,
ba da ba da da da dee.
Hold it full note value.
NARRATOR: And the
student performers.
ABRAHAM: I thought it
was really phenomenal
the way he uses
different colors,
and the way they kind
of play off each other.
I really, really enjoyed it.
NARRATOR: The Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
wind ensemble
presents "Awakening."
JOURNALIST: Activists in Cairo
today pressed their demands
that Egypt's military rulers
step down immediately.
HARRIS: I can remember
driving to MIT on my commute
and listening to the radio--
JOURNALIST: Demonstrators say
they'll intensify pressure
for an end to army rule--
HARRIS: --and
hearing the passion
in the voices of the people who
were participating in the Arab
Spring.
[CHANTING]
If I could somehow get someone
to write a piece of music that
would have our students have
to think about the Arab Spring
movement, what it means, and
get some historical context
as it's happening right now.
That was my goal.
We are extremely honored
to have an MIT alum back
on campus, Jamshied Sharifi.
[APPLAUSE]
SHARIFI: Hey everyone.
HARRIS: Jamshied Sharifi is
a New York-based composer
and producer.
He's an artist that is equally
comfortable in the fields
of world music, in pop music,
in composing original music,
in writing music for film.
SHARIFI: I'm digging it.
It sounds really
good in here, too.
HARRIS: He graduated from
MIT in the mid-1980s.
And he directed, for a number
of years, the MIT Festival Jazz
Ensemble.
So here is someone
who really knows
what it's like to make
music at MIT, how it feels.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We think of MIT as one of the
world's great institutions
for engineering and
science, but in fact,
the arts and humanities have
been thriving here for decades.
And I think it's
something that's
been a part of the fabric
of MIT for many, many years,
but it's not as well known.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHARIFI: "Awakening" is
a piece for wind ensemble
that I've written on the
theme of the Arab Spring.
One thing that I
tried to avoid is
thinking that I
was going to make
any sort of definitive
statement about the Arab Spring.
Close to two years after
things have happened it's still
a feeling of guarded optimism.
It's not a piece of
traditional Arabic music.
My records neither are
traditional Persian music
or Middle Eastern music.
They're a mix of a lot
of different elements,
a lot of things that
I've heard and studied.
I mean, I had an
education in jazz.
I spent a lot of time
playing classical music.
I've played in pop bands.
I mean, I'm a hybridized person.
I'm half Persian
and half American.
So I'm pretty comfortable
mixing those influences.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HARRIS: I've had a fantasy
for quite some time
to have him write for
the MIT Wind Ensemble.
He's never composed
for the idiom
of a wind ensemble, a company of
woodwind, brass, and percussion
players.
And he's someone who has a
kind of artistic restraint
in his temperament.
That colors in a very
beautiful way everything
he does in music.
SHARIFI: When you're dealing
with a new piece in front
of an ensemble, the
first thing you do
is play it through and let
them make their statement,
before you have anything to say.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ABRAHAM: We re-worked
the ending a little bit.
We got to hear specifically
Jamshied talking to Fred,
and to kind of see those two
come together was a lot of fun.
HARRIS: I think I maybe
went too far the other way,
so I kind of have
to bring it back.
SHARIFI: It's
better than the ink.
That's all I can say.
JACKSON: Middle Eastern music
has a lot of quarter tones.
But when you're writing for
a college wind ensemble,
you can't expect them to
learn how to play quarter
tones in one concert cycle.
He said for him it was
interesting to have
to figure out how to get that
element of the music in it.
ADAMS: The baritone sound
is just amazing to me.
The trumpet solos,
the woodwind features,
they just all come
together really well.
SHARIFI: I've never really
seen the quote unquote
division between the
arts and sciences
as any kind of dichotomy.
To be a complete
person, it makes sense
to be educated in both.
So having a vibrant arts
program at a school like MIT
is important for making
complete human beings,
for making human beings
that connect to the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HARRIS: As you
know, there's things
that happen in a concert that
can't happen in a rehearsal.
Everybody brings
their best game.
And also as a listener,
as a composer,
you can really let go.
It's just the concert.
This is what it is.
It's just time to enjoy
it and let it flow.
[APPLAUSE]
SHARIFI: The first
movement gives us
a sense of place, which
is the Middle East.
And it has a short section
which talks about the event that
sparked the Arab
Spring, which was
the self-immolation
of Mohamed Bouazizi,
and goes on to
musically illustrate
how that event led two uprisings
all over the Middle East.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The second movement is a very
reflective and quiet movement
in which I'm imagining the
participants and observers
of the events of the Spring
just taking stock of what has
happened, and reflecting on it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And the third movement
is a call to action,
or a call to continued
action in the hopes
that what happened
in the Arab Spring
continues to bring better
political and human situations
in the Middle East.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
HARRIS: Music is clearly
one of the great innovations
of humanity, passed
onto us from nature.
The word awakening kind
of conjures this idea
that you're coming
forth with something,
but yet it might not
be fully realized.
This power of reflection
and contemplation
is so needed today.
And I think that
awakening in its own way
provides a vehicle for that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]